These days, the idea of erasing something
like a film from existence is kind of ridiculous
— nothing disappears completely.
Still, that doesn't mean that studios haven't
occasionally done their best to bury a particularly
embarrassing film.
Here are some movies that studios tried, and
mostly failed, to erase from existence.
Fantastic Four
Famously filmed on a budget of around $1 million,
the 1994 Fantastic Four film was never officially
released, being unexpectedly cancelled just
a few weeks before its official premier.
Since then, however, low-quality bootleg copies
of the film have found their way onto both
the internet and DVD.
"Look at me!
Ahhh!"
According to legend, the film was so bad that
the then-executive at Marvel Entertainment
Avi Arad bought the rights
to the film moments after seeing an advanced
copy and ordered that it be cancelled to protect
the Marvel brand.
Arad would later claim that he additionally
ordered every remaining copy of the film be
destroyed.
Well, the joke's on Marvel: the film Arad
thought was so bad that it had to be buried
has a higher Rotten Tomatoes score than two
of the three Fantastic Four films that have
been released since.
"Look at it!
See it!"
The Big Boss - Mandarin cut
Regarded as the film that made Bruce Lee famous,
at least in Asia, The Big Boss is your standard
1970s Hong Kong action movie and features
all of the Bruce Lee staples fans would eventually
come to expect in his movies.
The only problem is, a chunk of the movie
is missing.
Before it was released, the original cut of
The Big Boss was effectively destroyed by
Hong Kong censors.
Known as "The Mandarin Cut," this more complete
version of Bruce Lee's first major film was
more violent, and countless scenes were altered
or completely cut from the movie.
It's highly unlikely that Bruce Lee fans will
ever see a complete version of the film with
all of the cut content put back in, largely
because nobody knows if it still exists.
Citizen Kane - Colorized version
There's little that can be said about Citizen
Kane that hasn't already been said, so let's
just talk about that time in the late 1980s
when media mogul Ted Turner decided that it
would be a good idea to try and "fix" Citizen
Kane by colorizing it.
According to an interview with colorist William
Schaeffer, at least 10 minutes of Citizen
Kane was colorized before the project was
put to a stop.
A friend of Orson Welles later claimed that
one of the last things the director said was
"Don't let Ted Turner deface my movie with
his crayons."
Depending on who you ask, the colorized footage
was either shelved or erased.
To date, only around a minute of the footage
has emerged, most recently in an obscure '90s
BBC documentary about the film.
The Star Wars Holiday Special
Until the prequels came along, the Star Wars
Holiday Special was long considered the single
worst piece of Star Wars content ever made.
It aired only once, the special was quickly
swept under the rug by Lucasfilm.
George Lucas was reportedly very disappointed
in the special, and he saw to it that it was
effectively buried by having it left out of
"complete" edition box sets and forbidding
TV stations from airing it.
According to legend, only one person had an
official copy of the special: Carrie Fisher,
who claimed she received one in trade for
recording the commentary of one of the Star
Wars DVD box sets.
Why did she want a copy?
She said that she wanted something she could
play at parties when she wanted people to
leave.
"It is so bad, it's not good.
It's painful, really.
It's dental work."
Superstar: The Karen Carpenter Story
Released in 1987, Superstar: The Karen Carpenter
Story is a short film that chronicles the
final years of singer Karen Carpenter's life.
Only instead of using archive footage or actors,
the film was made almost entirely with Barbie
dolls.
"Karen and Richard Carpenter… just a couple
of kids next door."
Although the film was intended to provide
a sympathetic overview of Carpenter's life
and the struggles she faced, it was decidedly
less kind to her family.
Her brother Richard sued director Todd Haynes
for unlicensed use of The Carpenters' music,
and virtually all copies of the film were
quietly destroyed.
Haynes himself was banned from ever airing
the personal copy he had tucked away.
This didn't stop resourceful fans — today,
several low quality versions have surfaced
on YouTube.
Nosferatu
Considered by film buffs to be one of the
most influential horror movies ever made,
Nosferatu was among the first films to adapt
Bram Stoker's Dracula to the big screen.
The problem was, Stoker's widow never gave
anyone permission to make the movie.
The first thing she did after the film came
out was sue Prana Film, the studio that released
it.
When the courts ruled that the film was a
blatant rip-off of Stoker's novel, they ordered
that every copy be destroyed — an order
that was carried out so thoroughly, it's believed
only a single copy of the film survived the
purge.
This copy then circulated over the coming
decades until the copyright on the Dracula
novel expired and the film could come back
to life.
"Nosferatu!"
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!